and joining me now the chief executive
of mckenzie intelligence forbes
mackenzie to talk about the latest
developments on the ground uh forbes
good to see you and let's start with
what's been happening overnight and into
today and the attacks on levy right on
the border with poland can you tell us
what information we have so far that's
right um there was a number of missile
strikes through the night in lev on
electrical substations
and what we see here from intelligence
perspective is that the russians are not
doing well at all in the donbass region
across here to the south
car cave to the north they've take
significant losses again failing to make
the ground that they would hope to make
and the south in particular there's been
movements of some two to three
kilometers per day which from a maneuver
warfare perspective really isn't where
it should be
in lev we have
depth pose where nato western capability
is moving towards
and it's an imperative for the russians
to strike it while it's there before it
can be moved forward to come into effect
so therefore there's a real race against
time um yeah let's talk about the date
that's been talked about a lot over the
next the last few days and that's the
eighth of may and the significance of
that in moscow and how that could pla
play out on the map we're looking at now
that's right now the ninth of may is
is is is victory day and it's victory
day because it celebrates the russians
beating the the nazis at the post world
war ii
and there will be a big parade in the
red square putin will give a speech
um the military parades will have an
audience
um
from an international perspective it
shows strength from a domestic
perspective putin must have a good news
story attached to it and we see in
mariopol to the south is this still
works a renewed attack
on on the steel works now there's of
battalion who are there are a pro-right
base italian and if putin is able to
combine the narrative
of defeating nazism in his words to the
south
combining that with the victory post
world war ii that will set him in good
stead for the domestic audience yeah
things ramping up heading towards that
key date of the ninth of may and forth
mackenzie thank you we'll talk to you
later on in the programme about the
latest unfolding developments in ukraine